make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob
and i am super tired at the moment so
you guys are gonna have to bear with me
i know we don't normally do these until
the end of the week but i'm actually
going out of town and i'm not gonna be
back until midday
on monday so in order to make sure my
editors have content to edit i'm gonna
go ahead and record this and throw it
out there but we are covering our beyond
omega level series earlier and in this
video we're covering white lantern kyle
raynor now
as we always do with this series we're
going to outline the origins and powers
of this particular character so kyle
rainer first appeared in green lantern
number 48 1994 and was created by ron
mars and daryl banks now kyle's father
was a cia agent that abandons his mother
before kyle's born and so kyle grows up
in a modest home and grows to become a
comic book artist
and lives a fairly ordinary life until
he's visited by ganthet now ganthet is a
member of the guardians of the universe
a group of cosmic entities that founded
the green lantern corps and at the time
that he visits kyle
ganthe was the only living member of the
guardians of the universe as the rest of
them had all been killed by hal jordan
who'd been driven mad by the feared
entity known as parallax now for those
of you guys who are unfamiliar with the
green lantern mythos a side track from
this for a second those you guys who are
unfamiliar with the green lantern mythos
a lot of people are really confused by
this concept right and i've got videos
explaining all this but the way that it
worked out is that when when parallax
originally
was introduced in dc comics it was just
hal jordan calling himself parallax
right the embodiment of fear
parallax was not an actual entity he was
simply just a name that hal jordan
called himself now following the the
emerald twilight story and going into a
whole bunch of other events somebody
basically elevated kyle rainer to having
the power of ion right where he was
basically this super powerful
green lantern entity and so kyle rayner
basically resurrected
all the guardians of the universe who in
turn recreated the green lantern corps
and now this is important because when
jeff johns took over his handling of
green lantern that's when he started
introducing the entity of parallax right
so he introduced like the actual
entities themselves
beings that represent the different
aspects of the emotional spectrum so
those didn't exist until jeff johns took
over the title
before that parallax was just a name
that hal jordan gave himself so i
figured i'd kind of clear that that
little bit of confusion up hopefully it
helps you guys but regardless uh ganthe
gives kyle the last remaining green
lantern ring but does so
unenthusiastically simply saying you
will have to do as he gives kyle the
ring without offering an explanation as
to why he was chosen now it's not until
2012 about
a year after dc had rebooted his
continuity with the new 52 that the
reason for ganthet choosing cal rainer
is revealed and it's changed that he was
chosen for his ability to overcome great
fear it's also in the new 52 continuity
that we see kyle become a white lantern
now how that comes about
is that kyle is basically going about
his business as a green lantern when
blue red yellow indigo and violet rings
appear to him and claim him as their
rightful bearer however kyle isn't
attacked by members of the sinestro
corps red lantern corps star sapphires
and indigo
tribe each one representing each of
those rings that came to kyle but he's
aided by the blue lantern saint walker
who accompanies kyle to owa to figure
out what's going on but on the way
kyle is located and claimed by the final
ring on the emotional spectrum the
orange lantern ring now on oah the
guardians try to take the ring from kyle
and interrogate him but all of them bond
themselves to kyle and he becomes the
first individual to harness the entire
power of the emotional spectrum and so
kyle struggles with his ability to
control all the emotions of the spectrum
for a while but upon mastering his
ability to control them he becomes the
white lantern and green lantern new
guardians number 16. now as the white
lantern kyle gains the abilities of each
of the lantern core
and as green lantern kyle's able to
create hard light constructs that are
only limited in form by his imagination
and due to kyle's background as an
artist he's known for creating the most
original constructs of any green lantern
now from the yellow lantern or sinestro
corps he gains the ability to sense the
fears of his opponents and use that
knowledge to influence the form of his
constructs he's also able to harness the
caustic red plasma emitted by red
lanterns the ability to teleport that's
inherent to the indigo tribe and the
ability to cause others to experience
love of the star sapphires from the blue
lantern ring kyle gains the ability to
instill hope
and finally the orange lantern ring
grants him the ability to make
additional members of his lantern corps
from hard light now in addition to being
able to harness the abilities of every
lantern corps
kyle's able to heal the injuries of
others but is failed when he tried to
resurrect the dead
kyle also possesses a number of other
abilities such as phasing through solid
objects generating force fields becoming
invisible
flying at super speeds and projecting
powerful blasts of energy
during a battle with a villain relic
kyle ventures past the source wall which
exists at the end of the known universe
separating it from the source of all
existence when he does so
he learns the operating code for reality
and gains the ability to rewrite reality
itself we see this manifest in the
existence of the entity known as
oblivion who was the personification of
kyle's own anger
greed fear and anxiety that he
unwittingly wrote into existence we
learned that the code for reality that
kyle discovered is actually the life
equation a mathematical formula proving
the value of life now once the life
equation bonds to kyle and his white
lantern ring he becomes a being of
immense power able to bend reality
itself to his wishes when he encounters
raga a once living planet he's able to
bring it back to life
suggesting that he advanced past his
previous inability to resurrect the dead
now during a conversation with the
guardians of the universe they tell kyle
that as long as he's in possession of
the life equation he can do anything
suggesting that he's actually omnipotent
possessing the life equation begins to
wear on kyle however as he describes it
as something that's eating away at him
to the point where he feels
endangered of being consumed by it and
during his final showdown with oblivion
kyle is told that if he keeps a life
equation eventually the entire universe
will be remade to his liking and
eventually he would end up destroying
those he cared about and so kyle
ultimately decides that the power of the
life equation is too vast to be
entrusted to one person and so along
with the guardians of the universe he
creates six more white lantern rings
each with a fragment of the life
equation
creating a new white lantern core now by
doing this not only does he prevent
himself from being consumed by the life
equation but because he was no longer a
threat to the existence of reality
oblivion the manifestation of kyle's
insecurities and negative personality
traits was no longer necessary and
subsequently
vanished into nothingness and so by
giving up his power kyle was able to
eliminate another universal level threat
by ending oblivion's existence
now because kyle gives up sole
possession of the life equation we never
get to see him at his full potential but
from the few instances that we see of
him warping reality we can clearly see
that kyle is capable of reshaping all of
existence which places him
well beyond omega level but even if we
put the life equation to the side
simply having the abilities of all the
various lantern cores would make kyle
one of the strongest characters in the
dc
universe and capable of doing some
serious damage but if we couple that
with the ability to warp reality it
becomes a no-brainer
that kyle is probably one of the most
powerful entities in the entirety of the
dc universe for only a brief period of
time
while he operated as the white lantern
but with that being said guys we're
going to bring this video to an end if
you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and i will catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you